we're joined now by musician
and activist uh roger waters in new york
many thanks for joining us on al jazeera
and the newshour
you of course have been involved in uh
trying to lift the voice of palestinians
for a long time now what is your
initial reaction to what is happening
there now
well i've just been watching the last 20
minutes of your program
so uh like marwan bishara
who who mentioned this fact i saw
netanyahu standing proudly and smugly
in front of an f-16 or whatever that
sleek looking israeli fighter jet was
that was over his shoulder
boasting about his power
to inflict pain on his neighbors
you can make this this is like
this is a classic example of the
sociopath
using his power and the power of his
platform this man feels
in violet he feels that he can get away
with anything
and the sad and sick thing is he can
and why can't he because exactly is your
correspondent
who i've just been watching said only
joe baude biden or the government of the
united states of america has the power
to press the off button turn off the
switch of the
genocidal bombing of the of the
palestinians in gaza city
so what's i mean i am
i'm stunned by the
callous disregard for human life and
human rights and freedom and the law
and and also um the opinions of
uh the whole of global civil society who
by and large
more and more are coming to be 100
understanding that this racist apartheid
exercise which is the state of israel
has got to be brought to heal
by us we the people of the world we
the peoples of the united nations
so let me pick you up on that when you
talk about
looking at yourself as a musician as a
famous musician
what can you do uh to make a difference
to what is going on uh in in that
particular conflict
i can stand on this rooftop and shout at
the top of my lungs
and i'm not saying until somebody hears
me because people do hear me i actually
do have a platform of sorts
i can encourage the choir to sing with a
louder and louder and louder voice every
day
not just in palestine but all over the
world
to sing we shall overcome together
because we will
because this situation is completely
untenable
everybody with an iq above room
temperature
knows that israel is a failed zionist
experiment it is over this
will not go on i my the the meeting i
had before this i had a webinar with
some
some people in england there's going to
be a huge mass demonstration in london
on saturday where they're going to march
hundreds of thousands of people will
march carrying palestinian flag
from the embankment to hyde park okay
this is happening in cities
all over the world why
you know you i keep remember getting his
name marwan bisharda
was baffled he claims and i'm sure he is
i noticed as well in the previous clip
my friend riad mansour
who i met in 2012 when i spoke at the
united nations
the human rights commission okay
when the russell tribunal was in new
york discussing these matters this is
now
nine years ago okay and we're still
looking at pictures of this
man here in his blue shirt with his
either dying or
deeply deeply damaged child in his arms
and yet somehow the united states of
america
refuses to lift a finger to stop it and
they could
joe biden could stop this in a heartbeat
why don't they we honestly don't know
but that's all i can do
all i can do is to continue to express
my
absolute outrage and to try and stop
people referring to this as a war or a
conflict
it's not it's the oppression of an
indigenous people
by a settler colonialist emperor
it's interesting i'm sorry
i'm sorry to interrupt you roger uh it's
interesting that you say you have a
platform you do have a platform
uh as a very famous musician and there
are others like you
who want to get their voice heard
on this issue but as you say when it
comes down to it
the governments of the world are holding
back
how is it that platforms like yours can
really make a difference
listen my platform is not the fact that
i used to be in the pink floyd
my platform is the fact that i've got a
heart and i
care just like all my comrades all over
the world who are in
solidarity on this issue and many other
issues
okay so that that's where the platform
is we
there are we are many many many there
were 20 million of us in the streets in
2013
before the invasion of iraq for instance
that's a lot of
people okay we didn't prevent
bush and blair and cheney and and the
rest of them
from continuing with their insane
endeavor in iraq
but we did take to the streets and we
did speak out
and we were heard and people recognized
in us outpouring of our hearts and
condemnation of this
genocidal murder people recognizing us
that need for human beings to act
collectively and to express a love for
one another across all religions
nationalities borders
walls separation this that and the other
and they recognize that that essentially
is what brings joy to their lives
as much joy as we can get and that the
murder of your neighbors
provides you with nothing in the end but
darkness and
misery okay so that is what gives me a
platform is those beliefs
nothing to do with music okay thank you
for your time
uh roger waters speaking to us there
from new york
thank you very much hey gaza my heart is
with you
my heart goes out to you i bleed for you
let's put an end to this cease fire now